and your confidence should come from who
you are and what you do and you need to
do the work to love yourself sometimes
people just like look at me and start
laughing just and I yeah so I embraced
it at five years old everyone just wants
to quit their day job for their dream
but then when you get there you're like
oh this sucks too like I'm no happier
now than I was and I was waiting tables
need motivation watchit Optima believe
me Shane what's up at 7:00 my one word
is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and make a difference
with it so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and chew in today's lessons from
a woman who went from having a deal with
anti-semitism as a child growing up
having her father being diagnosed with
multiple sclerosis and working as a
bartender and waitress for two years to
becoming a successful and award-winning
comedian and actress she's Amy Schumer
and here's my take on her top ten Rose a
success enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one be inspired by negativity
we're afraid of insults so many women
don't speak up if somebody wrongs them
just for fear of somebody saying
something mean about you absolutely but
you're different I am different
different I look at that as an
opportunity can you look at the trolls
as a way to inspire you yeah yeah I
haven't I couldn't feel a mean internet
comment now if I wanted to I think I've
gotten so desensitized to it over the
years and then it just I feel such
sympathy for the people who feel
motivated to go I mean I don't even know
anyone that would write a mean comment
on a stranger's Instagram or whatever
right if I found out one of my friends
wrote something mean on a Kardashian's
social media I'd be like you're out of
my phone that's crazy it's crazy what is
wrong with you but it used to like
trigger you right I I used to it used to
hurt my feelings when I was you know
this is literally 10 years ago I did
that show Last Comic Standing and people
would I'd get compliments and then I
would just get the most hateful by a
while just cruel and I would think oh
you know I
and you almost accepted as fact like oh
I okay I'm ugly wait this is unbeatable
oh I'm you know the most disgusting
woman alive and and then after a while
you I thought they're both right yeah it
has nothing to do with that rule number
two my personal favorite listen to
yourself more honestly what I've learned
is not to listen to anyone for real yeah
the people advising me are great and
other than my publicist like no [ __ ]
she knows what's up she let me fall in
front of Kanye and Kim like she doesn't
she's cool but you know a lot of people
told me to host the daily show a lot of
people have told me to do a lot of
different things I've just said no I
don't want to be the the funny friend
and it like I'm gonna wait and so I
haven't listened I never listened to my
teachers that I
respect and yeah so it's really been at
any time I haven't followed my instincts
I've been burned so I've really learned
to listen to myself more rule number
three learn to love yourself that is the
new movie I feel pretty which you came
here in debuted and it looked funny just
from the trailer I saw it the other
night it is hilarious thank and has a
great message so I'm gonna explain the
concept to you guys it's about a girl
who is really low self-esteem which none
of us can relate to no she's really low
self-esteem and she she feels invisible
and then she falls off her bike in
SoulCycle and all of a sudden sees
herself just as a gorgeous supermodel
and everything changes for her and it's
you know it's really about learning to
love yourself which is what makes
somebody the most attractive and it's
true it's like everybody has some like
there are people that have all kinds of
just Morpheus like the you know body
dysmorphia and they think that they're
too fat when they're too skinny and
there's all kinds of so if you just
actually believe that you're beautiful
why not what's wrong with just believing
and knowing that because it's the
confidence like you said yeah just it's
all men saw yes and your confidence
should come from who you are and what
you do and you need to do the work to
love yourself yeah and then you feel
great and then you wind up getting a
chef husband
yes rule number four embrace your gift
I was playing um Gretel in the sound of
music and I love a good Nazi musical and
and every time I would come out on I was
five and every time I would come out on
stage everybody would laugh and I felt
really stupid and humiliated and I I and
the director could see that like I would
get angry and frustrated every time I
spoke or they would laugh cuz it was a
little girl like and and she was like
she explained to me no Amy it's it's
good when you make people laugh you make
them feel better they're happy and it's
a it's a great thing so it was really
explained to me that it was good and
then I had this just kind of ability
like sometimes people just like look at
me and start laughing just
and I yeah so I embraced it at five
years old rule number five live in the
moment did you have a back-up plan
no I never had any plan yeah I didn't
even have a plan for performing no I
like would just go job to job working at
forever 21 than being a petty cab driver
shampoo girl shampoo girl really yeah I
was the worst I lied and said I had a
lot of experience and that's something
you really need to be good at like yeah
cuz I was too gentle and there was a guy
that had like you know male pattern
baldness or it's like just hair around
the back and then what little thing here
so I was just washing his hair and he's
like wash my whole head I'm like no it's
spraying off your head at me so yeah I
got five I got fired from all my jobs
pretty quick yeah I had no backup plan
yeah but I mean now even now it's like I
don't know what's gonna happen I'm I
really take good care of both my
siblings so that one day I'll be able to
kind of Blanche DuBois my way over there
and they'll have to just like yeah just
like blue jazz and take care of me
rule number six find mentors guys how
many mentors kind of showing the way in
this regard like when you were coming up
or like did that not really exist
sure yes a lot of people like jessa
Karason as a comedian in new york who
just took me on the road with her she'd
give me like 50 bucks
and but then also make me pay for gas I
don't know who cares but I think that
you've experienced this too it's like
you know people like Ellen or Letterman
or Conan like when you you what you like
other funny people you so these people
would really encourage us and reach out
and be like you know Steve Carell I did
this movie had one scene and he was like
I want to encourage you to keep going
like you can you know you probably
thought you're not funny yet but you
could probably get there and yeah and I
feel really grateful to people like
Ellen or Gloria Steinem like people who
take the time and it makes you like well
I have I have a complete obligation to
do the same rule number seven find your
creative environment I write on stage
alaih I do stand-up so much like I'm not
gonna see my apartment til like
mid-april because I'm on the road doing
stand-up so I write a lot on stage and
then just hang out other comics I just
feel like creative and like those juices
have been flowing so I haven't had like
a major block for a while you just riff
with other coming yeah we just I mean
just we just trash each other like it's
just the meanest my friends are like the
meanest group of people and we just you
know someone walks in like if I walked
in wearing like they were just trash me
they were just even just hearing me talk
about like how I'm doing what I'm doing
they would just rip me apart and so I
think that keeping each other humble but
also on your toes ready to fire back
keeps keeps me pretty sharp rule number
eight be resilient you remember what
your first material like what you're
when you first went up on stage what was
it like why are you doing this to me it
was terrible I was 23 I know what you're
saying like you should have already
known but I didn't and I went up and I
was like skywriting that's stupid right
it's always fading if a guy proposed to
me that way I would be lying net like
there's no way there's no end to this or
you're gonna laugh like this is
eleven years ago and and then about the
the New York City crosstown bus I wrote
a joker it was like just the theis
anytime you feel it like kind of go down
when they like to let the air out of
that front tire you know somebody
atrocious is about to get on like just
like some leg that they have to carry
look it was eleven years ago but that
moment when you're being onstage and
maybe didn't go so well it's still
somehow it made you want to do it again
and again
why masochism I seriously any any person
is a comedian is a masochist and
delusional and yeah and I was definitely
knows that you really think that's true
a hundred percent someone's like okay so
you're gonna do this thing for the next
eight years and no one's gonna tell you
you're good and you're not gonna be good
and you're gonna have to live on the
road in hotel rooms making very little
money yeah and like it'll just be it's
constant rejection it's not like an
audition it's like every sentence out of
your mouth people are like no and you're
like okay what about this sentence it's
I'm in a great place right now but being
a stand-up is a hard-ass life and it's
you think it's gonna be fun you're like
oh my god if I can just quit my my
bartending job like everyone just wants
to quit their day job for their dream
but then when you get there you're like
oh this sucks too like I'm no happier
now than I was when I was waiting tables
I'm always pretty happy but it's there's
no I think we're all just always the
same amount happy rule number nine be a
voice of change you have actually
changed the way so many women perceived
themselves in their lives you have done
that through your work through your art
through yourself I will cry 90 seconds
don't worry it is true it is true and I
know you didn't set out to do that
because I know how it works
I know that just being yourself was
enough to bring the warrior to the world
damnit Oprah yeah well right back at you
okay yeah I I didn't set out to do that
at first I just wanted to perform and
make people laugh and then I I realized
people are paying attention you and you
have this not responsibility but this
opportunity to be a voice for women yeah
and I have done my best to rise to that
and I'm trying to catch up and learn in
real time so that I can what the
responsibilities yeah right Yeah right
people always talk about the
responsibility ask me to you know I've
often been asked about does it feel
weighted is it heavy no cuz when you're
just being yourself it just is right
yeah there's no fear right because you
really really trust your intentions and
and your potential which is sort of with
this movie that's what I that's what I
want and I think that's what all we both
want for women is for them to get out of
their own way and and have the tools to
live up to their full potential not let
anything hold them back like how they
feel they look or some flaw and rule
number 10 the last one before some bonus
clips have fun last time I was here
right from the show I got courtside
tickets to a Laker game that's fun yeah
cuz my business agent thought it was a
mad at him for sexually harassing me
well but no I'm like 33 so I'm just
starting to really appreciate that you
know they may and I well it's true I
can't speak for everyone I'm not like
sexually her up but in your 20s I feel
like you walk around like it walked past
a construction site and be kind of like
oh like don't look but then in your 30s
you know you I'm just like what about
this
it's like my skirts over my head on
there like we're eating but
it changes it really does it change so I
got courtside seats which you've sat
court sided yeah right I thought I went
I thought would be free booze it's not
it's not I guess we'd like be on the
team to get free booze so I go I get
randomly seated next to Dianna Agron
you know the actress she's on Glee she
played the cheerleader Quinn I mean that
lets you know how hot she is
yes yeah oh there we go there's the
picture thanks for yes isn't that great
she's like the most gorgeous girl ever
heard he was Quinn on that show to pull
off that name yeah like if my name were
Quinn on a show they'd be like oh the
Jolly Irish groundskeeper that does a
jig time and again you know but so she's
there is she not like an angel so and
she's the whole night she's like she's
like Beth because she knows people are
taking pictures of her I obviously don't
I learned a lot I learned that my
resting face is just a scowl it's just
and I learned you can see that I have
what I'm now calling an at risk chin
isn't it not a good section like sea
level it just doubles it's all just I
become the dinosaur in the Jeep in
Jurassic Park just so I'm like no idea
if he was seeing pictures I'm pounding
red wine and I I thought was free and I
I well I get red wine teeth right out
the gate and you know yeah like just
first like sniff of Merlot just True
Blood Mouse I look like I've been
feeding and I'm eating popcorn the way I
think we all ate popcorn which is you
know at first I always kind of start out
kind of like lying to yourself like oh
like one piece at a time you know and
then and then like you get a little more
real right and then eventually you just
like you get real real and it's just
good like I've split my lip trying to
get one more kernel
it's true my dumb mouth is true a bit of
you google me it's me I look like her
actually I look like her if she were
stung by a million bees it's true though
I look like her if you're like becoming
the whole you know she wanted to be
friends and I'm like I can't I can't she
we don't have we're not the same thing
like she was telling me hot people
problems you know she's like he won't
stop calling and I'm like I hate that
[Music]
now I've got three really special Amy
Schumer bonus clips on how to experiment
have confidence and understand that
there's no overnight success but before
that I want to know which rule resonated
the most with you what did you learn
from this that you're going to apply
somehow to your life for your business
leave it down the comments below
I want to hear from you thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much loved
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clips
you doubt what you do I think when I
when any comedian who starts out is just
delusional like the thought that you
warrant people's attention on stage is
very stupid it's it's less self-doubt
and more experimentation and it's it's
like a science experiment by the time I
film a special or do something on TV
I've tested these jokes to the point of
it feels like science like this is where
people laugh and so I'll try it and if
it doesn't work then I I stop doing it
except for a couple times or I'll get
really indulgent and it just makes me
laugh I think having confidence is sort
of a lifelong battle and you'll feel
like you're in a good place and then
maybe somebody makes a comment and you
got to pick yourself back up and I feel
like I'm in a really good place with
confidence but I still have days where I
feel you know I'm in my period or
something though I'm just like I feel
like hot garbage
yeah was it a real confidence boost to
you yourself doing that movie yeah
absolutely
playing playing her as super overly
confident and living that out I took
that with me and I it left me in a
really good place I have moments where
my confidence has definitely been like
too inflated and then also moments where
I feel really invisible and and bad
about myself too what do you do when you
get enough space I I don't try to rush
out of there you know I let myself be
there for a minute and I think this is
just a feeling it'll be replaced by
another feeling and this is not my new
reality this is just a moment in time
and I have a pretty good baseline it's
kind of hard to think with it at this
point I don't know if you have this
experience of where people like referred
to you as an overnight success and
you're like are you out of your mind
I've been on the road just like getting
eaten alive by bedbugs for for almost 15
years you know it wasn't an overnight
thing but there were so many times where
I thought like this is it you know yeah
I've been meeting with an agent I'm like
telling my friends like take me out of
your phone cuz I'm going to a new level
raise your standard Apple at the pool
core value is that we believe that
people have passion can change the way
people not one drop of myself work
depends on Europe it's something to me I
don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details